at the amount of the expenditures we
think that's a little bit High we're
narrowing the bill
the 16 beds or less to licenses of 804
I was not aware that there were so many
licenses for assisted living facilities
so it's going to redefine
the number of beds in the facilities
representative Edwards Edwards yes sir I
I just want to make sure I'm I'm reading
what you're talking about I I the only
piece of paper I have on 527 in front of
me is uh marked 0522 it sounds to me
like you have an amendment available to
you that's got a complete a more
complete fiscal note on it and so if you
have a different document we should be
looking at it I'd like to uh we just
asked for the amendment I'm not going to
have it available for about another 45
minutes
uh but the intent of the amendment is to
Simply replace the content here thank
okay so uh rather than uh confuse
everybody with uh with the changes and
the content of this if you would be so
kind Mr chairman and allow Mr Campbell
to come up
and explain what the facility consists
of and how the license impacts the
amount that's being asked for so the
content is good we're talking 16 beds or
less uh the amount is 115 or 16 a day
uh for Medicaid patients and uh he's got
all the details of the numbers so if he
would allow him I will turn this over to
him
questions from any of the committee
members
obviously we have an amendment we have
to look at later
and I that'll happen in division three I
apologize for that
so you said the next person to be expert
is is Ann Campbell will invite her to
maybe a little unorthodox I'm uh The
Honorable Campbell uh I think you
remember me from Farmington this is my
sister Anne and I was wondering if we
could just do our testimony together
yes give give us your name and we'll add
representative Petrie my real secret
name is Wayne
Swain Packy Campbell so now the secret
is out but I had the opportunity to
serve and then Hampshire legislature
with the chairman Weiler and we had a
lot so long I don't recognize you
know what's scary
I do recognize you and it was 20 years
ago and you haven't changed a bit
congratulations
I'm trying to follow my mother's lead
she looked the same at a hundred as she
I won't ask whether you were 70 then or
70 now
we got to get this button thing down
hit it once I'm good okay so uh my name
is uh Wayne Campbell and uh my
sister Ann and I started a uh assisted
living facility and I think that's the
first thing that we'll explain is it's
licensed that's the 504 license and we
have a copy of that license so when I
asked representative Horgan and
representative Petrie if they would
sponsor this legislation we put in
assisted living facility up to 16 beds
and that has a very uh important import
that means an 804 license
in the methodology from Health and Human
Services I think there was a little
miscommunication in that they included
all licensed facilities and that was not
the intent of the legislation so as a
former legislator I I agree that there's
some clarity that's that's perhaps
warranted and that would be that instead
of saying a an assisted living facility
up to 16 beds we would just say a 60
living facility with an 804 Residential
Care license and what that does is
really narrow the scope of what we're
talking about today and I don't mean to
put Health and Human Services on on the
spot and I wish I had let them know
ahead of time but I would hope that in
division three or later when you look at
that Amendment they could give you an
updated fiscal note that would address
The Limited number of beds in the state
of New Hampshire and quite honestly I
don't know how many there are but I know
that the 805 license which is more of a
Continuum of Care license more nursing
care are a higher level of
in room services for lack of a better
term it's different
but nonetheless an 804 facility as an
assisted living facility is a
residential care facility provides even
more services in my opinion than an 805
and what I mean is and my sister will
speak to this a little bit more is they
take you to the hairdresser they take
you to activities you're you're getting
assistance with your living you're
getting Med management so all the all
the staff are Med certified you have one
RN instead of necessarily RNs going in
and given the service at the same time
but you really have in my opinion a
higher level of service so again the 804
clarification is important because one
of the notes in the fiscal note is that
oh we don't know how to pay different
rates to different facilities when in
fact when you look at the fiscal note
they pay 58 dollars a night for some
facilities 804s and they pay 95 a night
I'm assuming for 805s or other
facilities so there is a precedent that
you would pay facilities at different
rates and I'm asking you to do that for
a couple of reasons one I'm partners
with my three sisters so anybody who
votes against this they're voting
against my sisters that's not
you know not a good idea so
um so when we opened this facility it
was right when covet hit it took over a
year to get the approval and I will tell
you there was a a substantial amount of
confusion on the requirements and just
for visual aid uh Mr chairman
in this packet you have 804 license
administrative rules different than 805
license administrative rules
definitionally they're very similar
requirements are very similar uh just to
give you one example 805 is nfp101 where
804 is a different fire Life Safety Code
a little bit less
so there's lots of little nuances like
that I don't want to get into it I just
want to make the point that they are
different levels of almost like a
private school versus a public school
just a different set of rules but
they're both licensed schools different
set of rules they're both licensed care
facilities one is specifically an
assisted living facility and that's what
this bill is about
um that right now for a small facility
to exist in New Hampshire if you get
paid the Medicare rate it's just not
enough because you don't know what
you're going to get in matching Social
Security funds or matching funds from
their retirement if they had one and
this bill not only will help this very
limited number of facilities but I want
to point out it's really going to help
patients in the facility if you end up
and I look around this room no reference
to the earlier comments but if you're
nearing that time frame where you might
be in an assisted living facility you
might want to support this bill because
what this bill would do is if you're not
quite out of you know you're still
driving maybe you can still self-shower
there's rules that that you have to be
able to do to be in one of these
facilities so if you're in that
situation you can only keep 72 dollars a
month
so if it costs 4 500 a month to be in
one of these facilities one of the
cheapest rates in the state
and your Social Security is only seven
hundred dollars
that's not going to even be the average
it's not going to get you to 4 500 so
I'm going to get you close with the
current rate of 59 a month
matter of fact if you increase the rate
to 115 dollars a day it only gets you to
3 200 from the Medicare reimbursement
rate and then you're still going to
probably have to pay on average is about
eight hundred dollars and when they
accept the client they don't get to know
what their social security is they don't
get to know what their retirement money
might may or may not be so here they
have these people in desperate need that
a lot of times are homeless this bill
will address head on the elderly
homelessness population in a very
positive way by providing beds for these
people that are high functioning enough
that they can almost take care of
themselves but not quite
and when they're faced with the decision
of moving into a facility and know that
the only funds they're going to have
available to them is 72 dollars a month
that's a problem
so if you increase it to 115 someone
who's making more than a thousand
dollars a month in their retirement or
more than a thousand dollars a month in
their social security or whatever those
different levels of income is they'd be
able to keep that money over the
thousand dollars not just the 72 bucks
so this bill is important not just for
the facilities but for this population
try living on 72 dollars a month
I know I'm happy that my mother is a
client in this facility
um and I'm probably not supposed to say
and I give her 200 you know I give her
money because she can't live on 72
dollars a month and if she didn't have
me as her son that's what the state
requires her to do so that's one of the
biggest problems I want to help these
individuals I want to make sure that if
if you understand if you're a person who
doesn't have a payee and we made the
mistake early on we accepted some
clients who didn't have a state payee
okay if you don't have a state payee and
someone's getting a thousand bucks a
month and they're being told they got to
give you 918 dollars of that money good
luck
I mean desperate people do desperate
things so then all of a sudden all we're
getting is this reduced Medicare rate
and we have a 72 year old borderline
homeless person in our facility paying a
third of the money they should be paying
it's a problem and it will bankrupt
these smaller facilities and I would say
to you that the data I'd like you to
look at is what where the 804 license
facilities post covid what are the 804
license facility after covid
representative Petrie from Farmington
Horgan from Farmington we have a place
called Hattie's place that was
demolished turned back on they were
trying to get an 804 license three years
ago when we were trying to get the 804
license and the state repeatedly wanted
them to be to an assisted care uh
license criteria to the 805 or that and
they claimed it was a miscommunication I
would boldly say that the state would
rather have Continuum of Care facilities
and that's fine if that's their policy
change the law right now the law is
licensed for 804 facilities and they
serve a vital and important role for
assisted living and there's a lot of
people that will be in that level of
care for a long period of time the
public policy problem is when they
transition to a nursing home there's a
transition that has to happen that's a
negative I can't disagree with that if
you're in a facility that does every
level of care you can stay in that
facility but you're really not you're
moving to a different section or you
move into a different thing and my last
point that I'll make take is that that
this bill favors small businesses
entrepreneurs like us from New Hampshire
it supports the North Country it
supports entrepreneurs opening up small
businesses and instead we have higher
levels of pay for facilities that are
owned by hedge funds or large companies
and I think in New Hampshire being a
small state with a lot of small
businesses being the backbone of our
economy and our employment whenever that
and I know this is a fiscal committee
but whenever there's a an opportunity to
fiscally support small businesses we
should lean heavily in that direction
because it's very important that we have
more of these small businesses because I
hope as my sister will tell you briefly
I know I talk too much I'm sorry
that we are able to provide a level of
care that you're not going to get in a
hunter bed facility we're able to
provide a level of care that it's her my
sister Elaine in the kitchen my sister
Sharon who's an RN and my mom doing
activities while she's living there it's
a wonderful facility and when we look
looked at all the facilities of buying
an existing location I saw a lot of
family-run small businesses that these
people were connected in the lives of
their clients and they and and quite
frankly I'm being asked to subsidize 11
people in uh Charlestown New Hampshire
and I do that because one of them is my
mother but I I if we don't have a
fiscally reasonable payment plan 58
dollars isn't it 115 is a reasonable
plan where maybe the people get to keep
a little bit of their money maybe we can
have a profitable business model and
maybe we can you know uh not continue to
go into debt but to pay down debt and
with that I'll let my sister answer any
questions that you might have about the
day-to-days of the facility and and how
important this would be to improve the
lives of their clients there
I think I kept track between what you
were talking about monthly payments and
daily payments but you seem to use
monthly for all of them but I have it
all written out and have turned a copy
over to your LBA staff very good
questions from the committee members
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair I for the sake of the question
just assume that everything you said
sounds good to me uh this is strictly a
process question do you do you do you
have somebody in working for a DHHS like
for Henry lippman or somebody we're
we're one we're less than one week away
from having uh the budget provided to us
to start working on and this this is one
issue of multiple issues that we have to
deal with in Medicaid and so rather than
dealing with this as a separate bill I'm
just asking you if you have support in
the department to where we could just
roll this into our budget process and
take a look at all all of the moving
parts and not just one piece at a time
I hope that I have support of the
department I think it's a good idea and
I think so do you know I'm not talking
about Hope unfortunately not being
connected in here every day like you are
I do not have a relationship with DHS
and I don't know what their position is
on the bill but I'd be happy to meet
with them get back to you before the
work session and I'd also just to answer
what I think is your question
representative Edwards if you want to
handle this as part of the budget and
notice a separate bill and I know that
this committee is going to look at those
rate pays for 804 and put it in the
budget however we skin the cat I'm fine
with that as long as we accomplish
getting 804 facilities a reasonable pay
58 isn't it so if you want to put that
in the budget I would welcome that I
don't think that we need a separate bill
I just think we need to accomplish the
additional payment level
thank you for the answer thank you Mr
chair
representative for a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in
two quick questions do you have any idea
how many 804 facilities there are on the
state and how many total beds do they
contain actually what I know is that
seven have closed in the last couple of
years
um those were all small businesses
Hattie's Place horseshoe Pines Freedom
Manor
um it's it's been a steady role of
places not being able to make it
financially between trying to pay their
staff a living wage
um we raised our wage to 15 an hour in
November of 21 and thanks to a state
Grant we're able to maintain that
throughout this year and give our
employees a small you know Christmas
bonus that they really appreciated
but
the 15 an hour in Sullivan County
doesn't get you an apartment on your own
you know if they're not a two income
family in New Hampshire they have a
problem with housing we have lost people
to South Carolina because of the housing
rates in here and pay the wage situation
um so we really really need to be able
to increase our wages increase our staff
right now we're running at nine beds
because adding two more people in which
we'd love to do puts us at a staffing
level that we can't support
um the 515 an hour would allow us to add
two more Medicaid beds would allow us to
add staff to
apply that support we do have people
that as mentioned shower
independently still drive their cars but
we also have people that are full help
they don't get their socks on by
themselves
we use both the underserved senior adult
population and we have mental health
members in our facility we used the
program that the state ran two years ago
for moving elderly patients from New
Hampshire hospital and Glencliff into
appropriate Assisted Living prop
population house homes so that they
could have the least restrictive
environment one of them it's worked out
beautifully Another one not so much
but we're struggling along with her and
that bonus that was given to us and the
pay rate that was given to us for that
year were both godsends that program did
a great support for us it's over now and
we're back to trying to live on our
budget and 58.66 a day is a budget
number that
is really difficult to support
um it is 74 by the way because they get
to keep but that's not enough to buy our
One smoker a carton of cigarettes on any
given month
um we end up supplementing his smoking
habit but you know we like to keep him
happy oops outside did we just testify
we encourage smoking in the elderly yeah
yeah he's been smoking for 60 years 60
years the chances of our breaking it
aren't good we do get him routine chest
x-rays and make sure he's not doing any
damage so far so good he'll be 80 in a
year
you know it's not a point that we're
going to take away from him at this
point we because we're a small facility
we can individualize the person that
likes to go to museums can go to museums
the people that like to go to the Animal
Farm can go to the Animal Farm we want
to support their individual growth their
activities of daily living and their
enjoyment of life
excellent uh representative I'll take a
crack at answering your question I did
go over with representative Horgan to
um legislative research and I asked them
specifically how many 804 facilities we
have how many beds we have in it and I
asked them how many 805 facilities we
had and how many beds we had in it so
the committee would be able to see the
difference in the type of facilities
that are out there but I think Ann did
an excellent job of saying we know of
seven facilities that have closed as a
result of the disparity in the payment
system from the state and if if they're
getting 95 a day I think we should get
20 more because we provide more services
do you have that number yeah uh the
research has not provided that to me yet
but I think we can have it by your work
session this afternoon
representative
excuse me
Papa Vichy Mueller thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking the question
I heard your testimony that basically
the you know lower reimbursement rate is
a continuous Financial challenge but you
mentioned a lot of closings during the
last couple of years and we are all very
aware of the huge impact that was added
by kovid and all those challenges
can you get us an idea of you know what
are those businesses that may have been
maybe barely viable without kovid and
kovid put them under or is this you know
have you seen stuff like this happening
before kovit hit I I just need to you
know understand a little bit how to
separate those two if you can offer any
information to that I know it's a
complicated question it is complicated
and covet hasn't helped because it has
decreased our available Staffing and
that has been an ongoing problem for all
804s because they make less money they
pay less wages but covet wasn't
necessarily the death now of any of
those places aging out and not having
people to take over the business you
know the ownership aging out
um these were all small family-run
operations privately owned they weren't
conglomerates like some of the other
places some of the larger places are
they were small business owners and
without the support of the state they
were running on too thin and Edge to
survive covet and at the 58.60 cents
point mark
it's incredible I mean we are one of the
more reasonably priced assisted livings
in the area has told to me by members
that have been looking for housing we do
take patients with challenges that are
slightly Beyond 804 level of care in
only because we have staff capable of
supporting those members with their
mental health needs we do a lot of
transportation
and most places don't they use the
transportation service companies which
our members aren't capable of doing on
their own I mean it's like putting your
mother in a taxi cab to Boston you
definitely not my late mother was in
Romania but no seriously I really want
to thank you for a very insightful
answer and for sharing your perspective
I find it very very valuable because you
know I'm a freshman I'm learning a lot
so thank you for contributing to that
thanks
Representatives
thank you Mr chairman representative
Stringham I want to make sure I
understand your bill as amended
um the as revised the special rate would
would apply only to 804 registered and
also be restricted to those who have a
greater than 50 percent uh Medicaid
occupancy so in your case if you have
you have I think 11 beds in um in your
facility if five or fewer of them were
Medicaid as proposed it would revert to
the existing rate
um and just just to kind of get an idea
if if instead of uh providing this in
terms of an increased uh per diem rate
if it was just a straight Grant if
you're looking at uh uh six people a day
for it for a year and an extra 60 bucks
it's about a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year for year one facility
do those numbers are they in line with
um kind of what you're you're here
asking for today yes sir
um the 50 Mark is to try and encourage
additional Medicaid bed rates because
right now
the Medicaid bed rate of some of the
privately owned facilities can be
anywhere from 10 to zero they have a
choice they don't have to take
especially private facilities don't have
to take a Medicaid bed rate if they
don't have a bed available at the time
and I want to encourage those kind of
places the the
804 section of a larger Continuum home
first per se
to take that 50 of Medicaid bed rates
just to get
some of the
seniors that are living in homeless
shelters that comes always madly to mind
because we're taking someone from a
homeless shelter this week
um because the encouragement of and the
opportunity for small business owners to
open more of these facilities is there
and is viable at 115 a night
I'd like to take a crack at answering
that
um that is definitely the original
intent of the bill was that you'd have
this critical level I would submit to
the committee that if you're going to
look at the amendment that we're Reading
Writing I did simplify it to just be an
804 facility the original reason I said
50 is because these bigger facilities
can have one or two Medicare beds and I
didn't know if there was a requirement
for them to do that and they're able to
average that lower cost out over 100
beds so originally the 50 was the idea
that if you're a small facility it's
kind of like if you're a private care
facility and you're charging nine
thousand dollars a month it's just a
different facility that's charging forty
five hundred dollars a month it's just a
different type of arrangement and that
social economic payment class usually
doesn't mix but I would say to you that
if you're going to narrow it with the
amendment I I believe the bill only
addressed 804 facilities because it said
assisted living facilities up to 16 Beds
which is definitionally what a NATO
force facility is so I don't think
there's any change in what the intent or
what we filed it just makes it clarify
that it's an 804 and in the amendment
the way we drafted it it left out the 50
stuff and again we live in this fluid
world so it's like what's better the 50
criteria or if you pay 804 facilities
that accept a Medicare bed and they said
well I wasn't going to accept any but if
I get this right I'll accept one or two
or three I would say to you that that
might be better than the 50 criteria I
don't know which which would drive up
more beds and I would say to you that if
you limit it to 804 it eliminates the
huge fiscal impact and I would submit to
you that if you pass this bill that the
fiscal impact is so minor it's not going
to throw off the whole state budget or
perhaps even be anything that we'd have
to really consider us a big issue in the
budget because it's limited to the 804
and then if it's limited to whether it's
one bed or fifty percent of the beds it
wouldn't make a big difference But to
answer your question five beds a year I
think that 150 number sounds about right
to what the impact would be on an
individual facility that had six
Medicare beds and that's the difference
between us you know losing 50 Grand a
year and maybe you know for the four
Partners oh my gosh they might make 20
grand for the the economic risk and what
we did this is not it is a money making
proposition and I believe in the
for-profit business but my sisters are
Saints they're Saints with what they do
every day
um I was a landlord for 25 years I can't
imagine the level of care that they're
giving these individuals and I mean to
go up there and have a drunk 72 year old
man
assaulting your sister
and having to deal with that
we um would also like to mention that uh
my brother God bless them is using
Medicare and Medicaid interchangeably
this is a Medicaid Bill Medicare does
not cover 804 facilities at in any way
shape or form our clients do have
Medicare to pay for their doctor bills
the majority of them have Medicaid to
cover the cost that Medicare doesn't
cover but Medicare will not pay for 804.
but just it's interchangeable that's why
she's my older sister
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you very very much good to see you
again good to see you that amendment
should be automatically sent to the
committee from legislative Services
um so you should see that sometime today
all right I'll next call on uh Gary R
Cannon
nharch which he will tell us what that
stands for
it's Gary cohoon
and NH Arch very cool okay the New
Hampshire Association of Residential
Care Homes
which is the state excuse me which is
the Statewide
Organization for residential care and
assisted living homes
thank you
uh and I'm sorry I like Alex katrubis to
join me if I may have him do that all
right we've got cards on both of you
that's fine okay
Alex's New Hampshire archers lobbyist uh
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm handing out a list of all
of the 804 and 805 facilities which is a
question that's come up uh we are here
uh in support of the bill however we
were not consulted or involved with the
drafting uh we represent New Hampshire
Arts which is the assisted living
facility Assisted Living Care Facility
Association in the state I did reach out
to the sponsor to try and coordinate I
wasn't terribly successful uh but right
now there are as you can see on the
final page of the spreadsheet that Mr
Ripple is handing out currently there's
6534 licensed beds for assisted living
in the state of New Hampshire 65 34.
that comes it's right on the Department
of Health and Human Services website we
don't have to go to house research it's
it's right there on the web for everyone
to see
of those 65 34 beds only 500 of them are
Medicaid beds and that information comes
from the Department dashboard that's
presented to the fiscal committee
generally every fiscal committee meeting
so 606 6500 total beds 500 are Medicaid
beds eligible for reimbursement under
the CFI program I know that you're
really behind on the uh the timing here
so Mr Cahoon is a former owner operator
of Friendship Manor
and New Ipswich he's an expert on
assisted living and the CFI program he
has Decades of experience so I'm just
going to suspend uh thank the sponsor
for bringing it forward but again we
didn't have anything to do with the
drafting or the coordination and I think
that might have uh solved some of the
issues that you've talked about this
morning and I just want to finally say
that I completely agree with
representative Edwards we need to look
at all of the Medicaid rates we have
issues with DD substance abuse mental
health uh all of the Medicaid rates need
to be looked at in in this budget not
just assisted living nursing homes
all of the providers are under an
immense Healthcare Workforce crisis
Meals on Wheels I I could go on so we
need to look at it in the budget process
so whether you retain this bill however
you want to go about it procedurally but
we need to look at all the Medicaid
rates going forward so I'll turn it over
to Mr Cahoon thank you Mr chair
thank you for the data you're welcome
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to address
you on House Bill 527.
um my wife and I own friendship manner
in New Ipswich New Hampshire for uh 37
years
uh we closed in May of 2022.
largely for Workforce issues okay I if
you to the extent that Workforce issues
were caused by code I suppose covet
might have been a factor but really it
was Workforce we simply could not hire
enough people to keep going
obviously part of a Workforce Solution
would be an increased rate allowing us
to pay a higher rate of pay to our
employees
it is I will admit it is only part of
the solution there are other demographic
reasons that the workforce is in trouble
um but certainly making rates higher
would help
um before I continue I did hand out some
written testimony there is a typo in it
in the last paragraph I talk about the
cost of building new facilities
and I it says 10 upwards of 10 million
dollars that actually should be 40
so that's a big typo yes all right
um
anyway
um there's no question that an increase
in rates is needed uh and essentially
for two reasons the first is that
there's a tremendous unmet need
and the second reason would be
with regard to the unmet unmet need many
of you may be aware that the CFI budget
if you look at that closely you're
somewhat misleading year after year CFI
does not expend all the money is
appropriated to it
and year after year they don't fill all
this authorized slots for clients that
are that are authorized
by agreement with the federal government
this leads some people to conclude that
this that the CFI need is therefore
being met that is not the case the
reason they can't expend the funds and
fill the slots is that the reimbursement
rates are so low that many providers
providers refuse to participate in the
program
now CFI is the overall umbrella that
covers it's actually the the wafer that
covers Residential Care
with Residential Care the the situation
is actually a little bit more
complicated uh it's difficult to
determine what the unmet need in
residential care is compared to the
whole CFI program with a CFI program
we know how many units of service were
authorized to fill the slots that are
that are open but we don't know how many
units excuse me and we do know how many
units were actually provided so the gap
between those two is at least one
indication of what the unmet need might
be unfortunately in residential care
Residential Care isn't authorized for a
client until the client finds a bed
and it's almost impossible to find a Bed
um the
what what appears to be the case if you
look at the numbers is that virtually a
hundred percent of the approved need for
residential care services is met but
that's only that's because of this
technical way in which that's it's it's
uh figured
um friendship manner is was an 804 home
um just to correct one thing that was
said before we were not a 16-bed home we
had 22 beds
804 homes are not limited to
um
16 beds
many of the 804 homes were sheltered
care homes in the past and the sheltered
Care Homes are limited to 25 beds but
they were in fact shelter care homes
that were 100 beds
um
now as as to cost avoidance when
friendship men are closed we were down
to 18 residents we had not admitted
residents for a couple of months because
we knew we might be closing so instead
of the 20 or 21 residents we normally
had we had 18. of those 18 11 were moved
to nursing homes
of those 11. only one of them actually
needed a nursing home bed the other ten
went to nursing homes simply because we
couldn't find a CFI ResCare bed
uh in addition there were seven
residents who went to CFI beds
there are two problems with this the
first is that the Satan counties are
spending much more for a nursing home
bed than they would be for a sea of ibed
and secondly this means that at least 10
people were denied access to a nursing
home bed who badly needed one
so these are the reasons in a very brief
synopsis why the rates have to increase
there was a question about the number of
homes that had closed obviously
Friendship Manor was one of those and
representative Mueller asked if there
were if homes were closing before the
covert epidemic and in fact there were I
testified in the budget hearings in 2018
about the closure of actually three
homes just before that budget process
um the
Gaffney home in Rochester which had been
in business since 1902 and the carpenter
home in Swansea which was a town owned
home and had been in business since 1937
I believe
and the biggest reason that homes are
closing then and they're closing now is
Workforce homes for the most part have
not been able to hire sufficient staff
and that was certainly true of
friendship manner
in terms of limiting the
increase to 804 homes I would submit
that doesn't really make a lot of sense
uh there are in the list that
um Alex has handed out uh 136 licensed
homes
of those 136 licensed homes only 53 are
are enrolled as Medicaid CFI providers
I'm not sure how many of those 53 are
actually providing Services less than 53
I can tell you that I know that a few
years ago this number was over 80 and
when there were 80 enrolled providers
about 40 were actively providing
services so
uh the 53 homes account for all of the
500 beds that are currently occupied but
it's a relatively small portion of those
homes that are probably accounting for
most of them
um of the 53 homes and again this
statistic had to do with the original
version of the bill only 12. are they
the ones that are shaded
shaded is the Medicaid homes
that accept CFI Medicaid okay I guess
those are the 53 then thank you they're
53 shaded that's right okay
uh so it doesn't really make sense if we
if it's in the public interest uh and
it's good public policy to increase the
utilization of CFI beds and I believe
strongly that that is the case limiting
it to a very small number of the
providers doesn't really make a lot of
sense
um I also would submit that the 50
um required participation doesn't make
sense
um of the
6534 licensed beds in the state
uh
5192 are in facilities of 50 beds or
greater
most of those larger facilities are new
our new facilities have been built in
the last 10 years or so
and as I said there was a typo in there
I talked about a cost of up to 10
million dollars that was a mistake it's
actually up to 40 million dollars
the majority of those homes if they were
50 medicated anything like the current
Medicaid rate would go bankrupt within a
matter of six months to a year
the the larger newer homes simply cannot
participate fully as it were in the
Medicaid Program but what they can do
and which many of them would be willing
to do is to continue providing services
for people who were there but have run
out of money
Mrs Jones moved into
Happy Valley Assisted Living
six years ago with a couple hundred
thousand dollars in the bank she has now
spent that money
and right now unless the home is willing
to basically give her a free ride she's
probably going to be asked to go to a
nursing home which again might be a very
poor utilization of a nursing home bed
the homes would like to be able to allow
Mrs Jones to start to continue but they
need a somewhat higher rate of pay
actually considerably higher rate of pay
to do so they also need some statutory
and Regulatory changes
um but that's for another time
um the last thing I guess I would say is
I had a conversation yesterday
uh with a lady who was the largest CFI
residential care provider in the state
um she was talking about the increases
in costs in the last year how she's had
to increase her starting salary from
12.50 an hour to 16 an hour how food has
gone constantly up
she altogether has 72 beds three
facilities one of six two of 16 and one
of 40. and what she told me yesterday
was if the current Trend continues for
another year or so I will be getting out
of the business
and my 72 beds will go with me
and that's it thank you for your
patience I would be happy to try any
all right I see at least three
representative papovichi Miller then
representative Edwards and
representative leishman
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
questions this is more of a request
could we uh get this spreadsheets into
us in electronic Forum because honestly
you know working off paper is not that
effective and you know would appreciate
that absolutely I have it in Excel and
I'd be happy to send it to you
representative Edwards for a question
thank you Mr chair I I we're going to
have substantial conversations on all of
this on Medicaid day in division three I
invite you all to come in when that's on
the calendar uh and then I'm horrible at
your last name I know Alex is your first
name you you you started to hit multiple
different types of bed rates if you if
you could maybe maybe I already have
this information somewhere but if you if
you to the extent that you're aware of
varying bed rates what they are for how
much they are and when they went into
effect last uh I I'd appreciate having
division three use that as a reference
document absolutely I will prepare that
and
presented to division three how can you
do that yeah all right thank you sir the
daily rate for uh Residential Care is
56.88 I I I I don't want to hear it I
want to I just wanted to make one one of
the comments there was a reference to a
95 rate which is oh you're talking
which is inaccurate there is no 805
right
thank you representative leishman for a
question
thank you very much Mr chairman and hope
this question is easy uh are most of
these facilities tax exempt or not for
profit I have no idea what between the
difference between 805 or 804 at least
that to my colleagues on division three
but I just curious
many of them are organized as
not-for-profits but not all of them the
smaller homes tend to be for-profit not
that they make one uh Friendship Manor
was a C Corp
um
technically for profit but again we
didn't make one my wife and I can were
able to do that for 37 years because we
didn't depend upon it to live one of us
always worked outside of the manner to
basically support our family
thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman
any further questions from committee
members representative McGuire
thank you I'm also not very familiar
with this is so there are some assisted
living in the state that are not on this
list for example my County I think has
Assisted Living no I'm sorry what I
think my county has an assisted living
facility is that right and some
Communists have assisted livings yes
there are three or four
is that it everything else that's
private everything that's private would
be on this list is that yeah
um assisted living is not a licensure
term the licensure term is is
Residential Care
um there is in RSA 161-j a stipulation
that someone who advertises as an
assisted living home must be licensed
but there is no Assisted Living license
so assisted living homes are licensed as
resident either residential care which
is 804 or supported residential care
which is 805.
may I follow it thank you a follow-up I
was going to mention there were two on
here that I recognize one I was on the
board of for a while that was run by the
Masons and the Masons supported it and
the one in Rockingham County the county
supports it so some of these are
supported by others than just the money
that's coming in thank you yeah I looked
for my county and I didn't see it so
anyway
um so
what's the what's the basic difference
between 804 and 805 is it simply 16 beds
or more no 15 or less no okay but it has
nothing to do with with bed size it has
to do with the the level supposedly with
the Acuity of the population served in
other words
how sick are they how impaired are they
what do they need in terms of nursing
Services it is a very very on
clearly defined in both law and
regulation though
there's a lot of overlap in other words
okay one more thank you
um the the fiscal note implies that
um 804s get get a one rate and 805s get
a different rate but you said that's
incorrect that's incorrect there are
there are two Acuity based rates which
came out of a pilot program and I
believe was in 2002.
okay
um it was they were intended largely for
memory care or Alzheimer's care
uh the pilot program was more or less
successful there were three homes that
participated in it one of which no
longer does
the pilot program was continued So
currently there are two homes that
receive those rates but only two homes
they are both 805s but it's not an 805
rate one of the things our association
recently requested was could we
go back to that concept go back to the
successful pirate pilot and have Acuity
based rates in other words open these
rates up to something more than two
homes out of 136. and that rate's about
eighty dollars there are two rates one
is about 85 the other's about 95. okay
are the questions from committee members
all right seeing uh now we'll hear the
from the counties and Kate Horgan from
the New Hampshire Association of
counties
thank you Mr chairman my name is Kate
Horgan I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties which is all of
you are elected and appointed officials
at County government level the
association does not have a formal
position on this bill but to answer
representative McGuire's question there
are three counties that also have an
assisted living facility they are
Rockingham Merrimack and Cheshire county
um the association would ask that if you
are to consider this to please do it for
all rates doing it for a small subset
doesn't make sense all facilities are
facing Workforce shortages small margins
all of you are members of your county
delegations you know your nursing homes
operated a deficit every single year so
we would just ask that you if you're
going to increasing rates you increase
them for everyone and not a small subset
I'm happy to take any questions that the
committee has
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for coming what is
the total number of beds in these three
facilities uh I would have to get back
to you on that representative McGuire
but I can certainly get that number for
you
representative Heath thank you
um thank you for taking my question do
you have any idea what the waiting list
is Statewide for nursing homes I can Mt
nursing homes thank you for the question
representative I can speak to the
counties uh for the nursing homes uh I
would the average is over a hundred
people for every single County right now
some counties are have more I know
Cheshire county for example I think is
at 120 right now and they just had to
close an entire Wing because they cannot
thank you
um
I
I'm I had a meeting with Jason Smith
who's managing the Rockingham County
homes and uh
a lot of what we talked about were
exactly those challenges about you know
the rage being so low it makes it really
hard for them to be able to pay the
wages that would allow them to retain
the staff and that's where all the
workforce but you know issues are
starting
does your Association have you know its
own guideline I mean this this is a bill
proposed but do you have any uh
you know broad position from your
associations in terms of what the rate
should be and if so could you provide
that those suggestions to us we do not
we are actually working on that Senator
Rosenwald actually has a bill that would
raise all Medicaid rates uh for all all
Medicaid rates across the board and we
are in the process of figuring out what
those numbers should be I believe it's
seeing none thank you very much we will
close the hearing on Senate on House
Bill 527 and is there a list
yep it's coming
oh we got one person wants to speak
uh good afternoon Mr chairman my name is
Rob Berry I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services I thought I
submitted a pink card apparently didn't
get to you I apologize for that
um to my right I have Miss Christie Roy
and she can explain what she does for
the Department
I'm Christy Roy and for the Department I
work in the rate setting area for DHHS
so we wanted to just provide a little
bit of information prior to the work
session we don't have a formal position
on this bill either but we did want to
give a little insight as to how we got
to our fiscal analysis so the department
does not believe it's permissible to
Target rates as is contemplated by this
legislation that being the size of a
facility and the Medicaid utilization
rate we base our rates on the Acuity
level of individuals within the assisted
living facilities so we have currently
three different rates the lowest one
being the 58 and change in the highest
one being somewhere around it's 95 41
41.
um so we're happy to work last one again
95 41 so there are two dementia level
rates so there's the standard
Residential Care rate for CFI which is
or choice for Independence which is the
56.88 the second rate is dementia level
one which is 84.74 and the third rate is
for dementia care level two which is
95.41 they're service based rates we
don't have a facility specific rate
model for this so that's where the
challenge comes in
um it's a service level rate so that's
where the Acuity would be it's
additional Acuity Services needed for
those additional dementia levels
thank you
representative Edwards then
representative McGuire I think hey thank
you to the department for coming to this
I uh I look forward to doing a deep dive
on all of this in in uh in division
three and you heard me ask Alex a little
while ago if he's got a sheet on all the
different categories of uh bed rates and
when they were established and how much
they are I I think if we had a
comprehensive document to look at that
would help us go through and figure out
what we want to do to the big picture
and not just one-offs sure and now we're
trying to also have something from
licensing uh come to the work session as
well to explain the differences between
hee 804 and 805 if that would help the
committee as well all right and you know
the way that works Mr Ripple schedules
with Nathan white and then you guys get
alerted okay all right thank you
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
coming so we heard earlier that um a
total of 535 beds are receiving these
rate these three rates I guess is that
true or is there there more that's
likely go ahead the for so for State
fiscal year 22 the total days that I had
pulled from our mmis system which is our
Medicaid management information system
was just under 200 000.
representative Prophet popovichi Mueller
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
being here and answering questions I
mean you've been here when we were
hearing the testimony about the impact
of the uh you know lower rates uh to you
know the ability of the centers to
provide service obviously that testimony
is you know narrow in the sense that it
reflects their experience for you as the
department could you provide any color
or information to us in terms of whether
the current rates allow for the centers
to sustainably operate or is there a
concern at the department level over
these Trends I just would like to hear
your thoughts on this
I believe we'd have to get back to you
on that we have to speak to some people
at the department to get their views on
it
um that's more of a finance three
question anyway but I thought while we
were here you know if you could share
representative Petrie
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
being here uh has these closings around
the state has that put you know
additional uh pressure on these you know
on finding beds
so I can't speak to that personally
um I will try to get something from
licensing here but I can say that I
would expect that that would put
additional pressure on
um on facilities and individuals who are
representative Stringham
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um uh the rates on
um
you mentioned that the the rates paid
vary by the Acuity is there anything in
the fee schedule that incorporates
things like local wage index Indigent
care factors or Capital issues or
anything that would affect that and
could you also comment on what you what
restricts you from incorporating a
percent Medicaid as a factor in setting
the rate
I'm going to differ to Christy in that
um so again it's a service-based rate
they were increased five percent from
hb2 in July they're a CFI rates so any
other CFI legislation would also affect
this rate
um in the rate methodology that was
determined I when it was set there it
was out there was an outsourced company
I believe that worked with the
Department to come up with those
original rates and then my understanding
in the waivers there's uh information
about updating annually based on the CMS
Market Basket for CFI rates and then
they are additionally
held to a budget adjustment factor or a
budget neutrality Factor so there's
plenty of complexities in that rate
methodology
it
quick follow-up
how many facilities uh have have waivers
on on the base rate uh I thought you
said some do
waivers on the base rate meaning the
waiver so they have an adjustment
so
um the adjustment is service level based
so it would depend on the qualifications
within that service or the the need of
this what's required for the service
it's not a facility specific adjustment
so if there are only two facilities that
would provide that additional level of
service or that additional level of care
and what's required for that additional
level care there are two facilities but
there's no limitation to the quantity of
facilities that could provide that
additional level of care if they so
choose they just have to I would assume
apply for and prove that that's the
additional level of care they're
providing for that service
foreign
representative Edwards for a question
thank you Mr chair this could just be a
really short answer uh the five percent
that you mentioned in hb2 it's my
understanding that that expires at the
end of this hb2 period and and rolls
back to the previous level unless
reauthorized in the next hb2 or or or is
that was that a permanent increase to
the Baseline
going forward
my understanding is it's permanent about
I can we can look into that for you yeah
thank you
historically adjustments to rates when
you're reducing it you have to prove
that it's not affecting access to care
for Medicaid so if there is an
adjustment to that rate a decrease it
would be a significant lift to prove
access to care especially with what
further questions from committee members
seeing none we did find your card sorry
we lost it that's all right
but anybody else that wishes to make
comments on
House Bill 527
seeing none I have on the blue sheet
just the two Campbells that have signed
in and and pro both Ann Campbell and
Campbell uh no other signatures on
there
thank you all I'm going to close this
hearing on House Bill 527. you'll be
hearing more from division three when it
will be scheduled for probably
continued on with all the other Medicaid
rate discussion
thank you all for your testimony thank
you all for coming
I'll close this hearing
so with that I'd like to open division
three uh where I'm going to meet
immediately put us into recess uh until
uh say 12 35 so that should give people
time to go get something to eat and come
back we'll be in here at 12 35 to deal
all right uh we were supposed to start
at 12 35 it's uh 12 50 15 minutes late
uh that's on me uh we're out of recess
uh we're uh here in a division three
work session
um on the calendar is to discuss House
Bill 49 that we've had in division three
for a little while House Bill 527 that
we just uh talked about in full Finance
today and could talk about it a little
bit today and the uh the star traction
of today is uh is sb1
so
um
I'm going to start with
I think I think to get a sense of where
we're at uh I I'd like to get a straw
vote uh I have been a supporter of sb1
from the beginning we're going to take
that up first I think sb1 and uh and I I
would like us I would like everyone to
tell us through a straw vote where they
think they are on sb1 and then we can
talk about an amendment to sb1 that's
the same thing as the amendment to 49.
so so those conversations will converge
but to establish a baseline I think we
need to make sure that there's absolute
Clarity on where people are with sb1 so
so I would I would take a motion to
um
know where it's going to be it's not a
real vote I'm taking a straw I want to
make sure I know where people are at I
think I think the public needs to know
where people are at on this
okay so Mr chairman subject to our
conversations of yesterday it seems like
we're formulating a good Amendment so I
would make the motion to ought to pass
on Senate bill one okay is there a
second
second okay
um so uh is there the discussion on this
is that the Senate passed sb1 24 to
nothing
this was an enormous high water mark in
the past decade where people have often
said that we needed to do something to
replace the sununu center and the desire
to do something
reached kind of a a boiling point two
years ago when the legislature
passed into law the closure of the
sununu center on one March of this year
that's just a few weeks from now
the legislature had an opportunity to
pass a committee conference report and
did not
the reason the committee conference
report failed it was really I think
predominantly a burnt round capacity
there was there were different views on
what the capacity ought to be there was
a position that went with the house
representatives of six the senate had a
vision of 12 with a flexibility of up to
and when that topic came up the
conversations broke down and the
committee conference uh
broke up and didn't didn't complete any
work
so here we are nobody introduced
anything last year to fix this problem
we creep into this year
now about to begin our budget cycle with
the sununu Center closing in a few days
and the legislature still has not acted
so sb1 is half of the legislature acting
strongly and convincingly with a 24 to
nothing vote
it's hard to beat 24 to nothing in the
Senate that bill came over to the house
for us to consider the house has looked
at this issue in multiple different ways
children and family law saw a similar
bill with House Bill 120 in which
division three was invited to that
then we had House Bill 49 where we've
gone through a lot of discussion deep in
discussion on amendments it started with
the Waller Amendment and then division
three came to a significant agreement
yesterday and and so we've got that and
so we are on the cusp of success in
doing our job and and so what I think a
vote on sb1 will do
will be to bring us to concur with all
of the hard work of the Senate that's
been done and supported by the
department
that's been done and supported by the
advocacy group and the public that's
been done and supported and we have a
letter from the governor
so out of respect for all of those
people
that have looked at this and have
delivered us sb1
I would like us to vote do we think yes
or no we can support sb1 or not so this
is not a formal vote this is a sense of
the committee
uh yes representative hole
thank you chairman
um I think yesterday in division three
we had a very productive session
um talked about a a number of things
somehow along the way we ended up with
this deadline of March 1st
that in some ways is an artificially
driven deadline by prior law
it's not like the building stops working
on on March 2nd
the
the goal of of kind of figuring out what
you want to do before you go do it is an
important thing to me as an engineer and
what I see now is we're trying to create
and spend money but we haven't defined
the location or what the facility is
before we even get there and we're
saying go spend right 15 million dollars
so
um
uh hearing what you said there's a lot
of people that say this is a good idea
and it did pass out of the Senate 24-0
but I think we're not quite ready there
so
um as amended by the Senate and passed
okay I I I respect your conclusion I
just I just want to bring some facts
that we've heard in testimony and that
that the we heard that the 15 million
dollars that found its home in sb1 was
the original estimate
um that we that came about as a result
of there being a special committee on
the sununu replacement Center uh and
that what we have experienced in the
past year or so of of delay is a very
strong inflationary problem with with
supply chain issues and that and that
delay in this case probably contributed
from going from a 15 million dollar
estimate to a 21.6 million dollar
estimate and I don't know what another
delay would do if if this is still a
good idea at the end of the day does it
become a 25 million dollar good idea or
not I I I do think we've been given some
some numbers and I can understand that
we've had bizarre inflation and the
United States over the last two years so
so that that attributes the distinction
between the 15 and the 21.6 I'm not I'm
not saying that to change your mind I'm
just making sure that the record's
complete thank you um
so I agree and this goes back to I think
yesterday in our committee or
division we had a a great work session
to work out some of these issues
um I'm going to bring come to page four
lines 30 and 31.
quote in no event shall the total
expenditures from all sources for the
design and construction of the new
secured Youth Development facility
exceed 15 million dollars end quote
right that is in severe conflict right
and that bill was drafted this year
we're not talking about something from
two years ago the Senate could have
in their in their due diligence put in a
number that was more representative of
the cost of a facility
that's on top of where is it and whether
it's for 6 to 12 or 12 to 18 and I think
our amendment that was proposed
yesterday to start looking at some of
those issues was critical that's why I'm
having trouble with what was passed out
of the Senate
all right thank you representative
Stringham you have anything to add to
um well I'm against sb1 as written given
uh our lengthy discussions yesterday and
uh the direction we were taking things
uh thank you uh representative Weiler
we have to pass something we're two
years behind there's a date coming up
within days
we can't just say we're going to kill
this and start over again there isn't
enough time next week we're going to get
the budget and we're going to be buried
in it we got to do something now today
to move this along if we pass sb1 even
if this thing's in it you don't like the
most important thing in it we've moved
the date out
then when we get to the spending and the
rest of it
we're going to
be able to adjust that within the budget
process and put it in hb2 if need be any
amendments to it that we decide needs to
be in there but we've got to pass
something to move the date away from
March 1st so I I wasn't clear I I'm PR
this is probably not exactly the way the
parliamentarian would run this but we're
talking about sb1 I still intend to have
us discuss the Division III amendment
that we came to agreement on last night
so so so I I want to see where we are on
sb1 before we begin to entertain The
Division III Amendment and to find out
if anyone else has brought an amendment
forward for us so
um all right so uh representative
Wallner
I would I would not
um support Senate bill one as it's uh
before us right now I would um take a
look I want to take a look at
um amendments to it and um I'm really
concerned that we still do not know the
location of this facility and I think
that that's one of the first things we
need to do is try to figure out where it
is going to be
and work with the communities and then
move forward from there and I think in
the budget is the place that we need to
be looking at the financial aspects of
this I would I would support
um the department has testified number
of times that they need additional funds
to get through this biennium and I would
support
um
allocation of additional funds for them
uh thank you for that discussion
representative
thank you Mr chairman
um sb1 is written I think as a division
we've pinpointed some problems with and
i would support discussion of the
Amendments that we have reviewed in the
past few days
uh thank you representative norgren
I agree with Mary Jane and Laura
uh certainly we did spend a great
session as representative hole said on
amending it so I think to move forward I
would suggest voting ought to pass on
the bill and then take up the Amendments
all right so I think we just took a
straw vote while we got the discussion I
I recorded in my head is three yay OTP 5
nay on passing sb1 or recommending a
passage out of division three does
anyone want to have me go around and do
a more formal Vote or would you accept
that it's probably three five
oh okay so
um thank you let's transition uh Mr
Ripple have have you laid out the the
current amendment that we worked on last
night
actually there was another change Dinky
Dinky little typo
that uh that has since been fixed since
you
Mr chairman was the issue of Quorum
addressed in that typo
there was a question raised regarding
yeah we can talk about that but but the
short answer is yes we we we we we we
changed the numbers of representatives
from the local community from three to
just being representatives to let the
commission find its right size and then
without a clear number of how many would
be on the commission we we made it a
majority of those appointed to the
commission so so I think that resolved
that issue and what we just talked about
is on we're jumping around a little bit
but since you brought it up on page two
line
15 and line 16 a version that you saw
last night said three representatives
and instead of saying three
Representatives we made it generically
representatives and and that was so that
we didn't waste motion we've we've heard
that there are three potential places we
could go
one of them doesn't sound like a it's
going to pass the common sense test so
why delay the commission looking for
somebody to sit on the board that's
irrelevant so so that's that's what that
that's why that got changed and then the
other little typo
from what you saw last night is on line
34.
relative to a commission
to study Community impacts uh that that
phrase is consistent with the way we
describe the commission and the
amendment and and last night had the
previous title committee to study Public
Safety so it's just internally making
the document internally compatible
there's no change
so
um
so we're looking at Amendment zero four
five four Hotel
it basically on step nine I think we're
unanimous that we want
um the the repeal of the closure date
um
I haven't heard any disagreement today
about the appropriation of 1.5 million
dollars so that they can continue
operations through the balance of the
year that's four months of operating
expense anything that they don't spend
would end up getting lapsed back anyways
so is there any discussion or we are we
okay everyone's okay with that
appropriation
okay so now we're down to line 15. uh
there's now some contention on what was
uh birthed in the walner amendment which
was uh putting aside the sum of two
million dollars uh so that they could
begin the department could begin to
acquire services for site evaluation
everyone says we need site evaluation so
there's site evaluation in that two
million dollars architect consultation
and development of design options for
any replacement facility we went on to
say that we want two options considered
we want an option for six to twelve and
we wanted an option of 12 to 18. so
that's that's that's in this version of
the amendment that didn't come in
initially but we added it in our
conversations and agreements last night
um Department shall present its
recommended site for the facility no
later than the 30th of September I know
that there's a lot of pressure to do it
sooner than that I think if we just
listen to what's in the wind it's
already been determined where it's
probably going to be and
I I I I I I I I I don't understand that
being as contentious as it has become
But but so be it
line 22 the appropriation contained in
the section shall not lapse in June of
25 this is different than the operations
money this is the
architect money and then the governor
can draw a warrant
so that is what is in line 15. the first
things first
is this consistent with what you think
we said last night this is a different
question than whether or not you still
support it today the first thing is is
this accurate
is anyone disputing the accuracy of what
we did
okay so so
um I I will say that I support
this from the walner amendment because
it makes sense you you on a critical
path we want a new facility so that we
can transition to a fully therapeutic
model that's in the benefit of best
interests of the kids best interests of
New Hampshire
and on the critical path
these Services site selection
is kind of the first step and I'm
hearing people say we got to do side
evaluation but we don't need to
appropriate the money to do site
evaluation we just need to do site
evaluation and so this is a do Loop in
the software world that just has me
boggled
so this is this is let's one step at a
time let's go do the side evaluation
let's go appropriate the money
so that was my discussion of lines 25
through 31.
are there other points of view we'd love
to hear other points of view
thank you
representative walner
well when I got home last night and
um I started reading this
I always went back to it feels like
we're putting the cart
maybe the whole train before the horse
it's just we need I think someone needs
to make a decision about the site
and I think one of the best ways to make
that decision is for the Department to
say where they think they would be
most in favor of being co-located
because they
say that there's a lot of there's a lot
of efficiencies there's a lot of things
to be gained by one site over another
and so I think that would be the first
thing
that needs to happen is deciding where
it's going to be and then the next part
of that is working with the commission
around that which is made up of people
from the the communities
and start working with them around
um the kinds of things that you think
the community needs to have available
needs to know about the um about the
program before we move into
architectural drawings
design all of those other things let's
decide where it is the sooner we do that
I think the better equipped we will be
to move forward and I also think that a
lot of this is really budget work
because there are
um still
sums of money that need to be
appropriated in the budget
so so the clerk for clarification would
you strike that entire paragraph or
would you perhaps reduce the amount of
money appropriated and limit the work
simply to site evaluation because we've
not technically done a site evaluation
which is the normal first step in
project management before you select a
site so so would you
preserve the paragraph and limit it so
that we put some money into site
selection
what I would do is I would direct the
department to make the best choice from
programmatic reasons
which site they prefer
and I don't think that would necessarily
need
financial support
if they were do that today would that be
dispositive in your view I mean it seems
to me like we would need something
formal from the commissioner or somebody
we I think we already know they want
Hamstead everyone wants Hampstead and
but the problem is if you live in
Hampstead
you have not been respected yet we
haven't gone to Hampstead to say hey
this is what we're thinking what what's
it going to involve well so what what
this amendment does is say okay here's
some money here's the commission go
forward and start working with the
various communities we we can't show up
and say in my view we've already decided
it's going to be in Hampstead now you
tell us why that's not a good idea
that's that's not the way this should
work this should be us coming to them
saying hey look we're looking at three
Alternatives and and this one's got
these advantages these ones got those
disadvant advantages and You by God you
are just right you know uh so so I I
think I think you're asking we keep
talking about process I think you your
approach breaks a normal process we
should do site evaluation and work
respectfully with the three communities
before we stick a pin in the na in the
map and say this is where it shall be
deal with it which which is my really
rough translation of what I'm hearing
you say representative and I apologize
it was that was rude I don't mean it to
be rude uh after two years I'm getting a
this I would have the department this is
me talking I would have the department
say where it is they feel is the best
location for this facility
from a standpoint of what
is going to meet the needs of the kids
the families
and to start that conversation now with
the community
and there's no reason to be speaking to
me there's no reason to be speaking with
three different communities all at the
same time when the department you may be
right the department may already know
where they want to go and now is the
time to start talking with that
community and start really understanding
what this involves
so Mr rips and I think I think we've
heard a lot from you and and picked up
on your reluctance to just answer the
question point blank is is this your is
this your supervisor your manager your
director your your assistant
commissioner in the audience
because I'd love to hear from you I
would like to hear from the person
highest in the food chain on this
because I I think poor Mr ribson is
being put in a highly awkward spot where
he doesn't have the authority to say
that it's going to be in Hampstead and
and if I were Mr Williams I'd advise him
not to say that if it is his friend I
would say I I don't think he should
answer that question but you you you are
a leader you you get paid The Big Box
come on up and tell us what you think
really think about Hampstead please I'll
do all due respect I think I think I'm
I'm a leader too and um and uh
to be fair right
there as I've shared there are three
possible sites that are being considered
I think it was pretty clear when we
spoke yesterday of the three possible
sites which one has the most is the most
advantageous and that is Hampstead but
until we actually do the work to do site
evaluation to determine if that's even
feasible for us to say that that's the
site would be irresponsible
right so that's I I don't think we can
give you the solid answer you won until
the work is done to see and even then
that might not be the final decision
because right the department also is not
the final decider on these things right
you work in an executive branch that has
a governor and executive Council so you
know the opinion that I express is not
necessarily what the final decision is
so you know I I understand frustration
and wanting an answer but at the same
time you know if I give you an answer it
it's an answer that I don't actually
have the ability to provide
and an answer that would be so it's an
army guy who trained Afghans how to
shoot we we taught them ready aim fire
we didn't teach them ready fire aim and
that's what I I think I'm hearing is we
want to just say okay we're ready go
ahead and fire we're going to go to
Hampstead and then later we'll keep
figuring out that's going to be the
aiming I don't want to do that I wanted
us to get ready I want us to aim at the
three sites and then I want us to pull
the trigger on the correct site there's
a discipline process here I'd love to
follow it and Madam Deputy Commissioner
would you read your name and I'll I'll
concur with with Joe and I think there
are many you know considerations that
need to be put into this I think Joe
presented yesterday to your committee on
some of the shared saving possibilities
um Joe and I work closely with Hampstead
Hospital but there may be other
considerations as well so we really are
not in a position nor is it our role to
be um to be stating what the site should
be so we can't get there today
okay I I hope the media is fair with you
we've asked you to step into a very
awkward situation and I apologize and I
hope you're treated fairly
representative Norton and then
representative Poole thank you Mr chair
um I would just like your comments on
we'll start today and I just was
wondering if you had any comments about
it
so
um in general right I still support
Senate bill one I think that the work
has been done to know where we need to
move this
um yes there's some questions that
aren't going to be answered until we
move through the process and you know
honestly I'd
I'd wish that we had the type of trust
in each other that we can move forward
and trust that we're going to make
decisions about these things in the best
interest of the folks that we serve and
it's disappointing to me that we don't
have that trust
um that's what I think is the right path
forward
the amendment you know there's some very
critical things that have to happen
right now the most critical thing that
has to happen right now is that the
facility doesn't close in three weeks
that absolutely needs to happen
hopefully by the end of the day today
that there's agreement on that
um and that there's movement on that I
would like us to move forward with the
rest of the package but that's the
absolutely critical point
you have a follow-up
a representable
thank you Mr chair
coming at this from a technical
background and thinking about process
right there's three options that are
currently in play I'm not aware of any
others no one has discussed any others
but typically you rank them relative to
one another
one another over a number of criteria
when can the department have that
information to us
I I think I've already kind of assessed
for everybody yesterday what what the
Departments
column so
um part of this also is getting some
feedback from the various communities
that are in play right so it's more than
just correct what the how the department
sees it one of the criteria on this list
by which we will be making the decision
right is how the community feels what
the impact of the community will be in
terms of Public Services a bunch of
other things that were discussed
yesterday in our division
I'm used to seeing this as something
called the Pew chart p-u-g-h which is a
process by which you do this you rank
your options on one axis and you rank
the criteria by which you're going to
score those options on the other axis
and then you just do do the analysis and
go through this I would personally like
to see that as soon as possible I don't
know how quickly we can do that that
might involve having a meeting over in
Hampstead might have a meeting in
Concord somewhere to find and get some
feedback that may take a couple of days
I hear you that we can't we need to
address the issue of closure right away
got it that's which is in my eyes at
least lines nine and following at a
minimum but I would like to see that the
department takes lead
and starts to schedule public feedback
sessions from these communities so we
understand that because that's important
I'm not sure if that was a question or
not but I guess it's how if that is the
request any idea how long it would take
to schedule that and get back to us I
don't know how long that would take I'd
have to look into that and talk to other
folks so let me ask you about
criticality I I know what the hot urgent
burning issues are the the two we need
more time we need some operations money
got it okay
I'm I'm pretty fired up on the idea that
we have some arpa money out there
that uh we have to hit some milestones
in order to be able to use it I'm not a
gopher expert but you know I I think
it's fairly clear that the longer we
wait the more at risk I can't measure
that risk I just think that it's there
that the longer we wait the more there's
risk so so
is it critical that we go ahead and
begin the site evaluation that's in this
paragraph on the two million dollar
appropriation is it critical that we
begin that and fund that now or do you
already have the money and ability to go
ahead and begin that formal Society
evaluation without legislative action we
do not have the resources to do any of
that the process that had been
envisioned working with the As and the
Department of Public Works that that was
going to be built into the contract with
the future you know design firm if
you're talking about carving that out as
a separate process altogether I'd have
to talk to the Department of Public
Works about what that would look like I
couldn't speculate as to what that would
look like so so just to close us I'll
come to your representative Weiler yes
or no do you think the appropriation so
that you can begin the contracted side
evaluation is
urgent is that a critical issue is that
something we ought to be doing like now
or not
I think that if we if the goal is to get
this right the goal that I've always
understood for the past couple years was
that this needs to get done immediately
right there were timelines put on this
that were incredibly tight and ambitious
under the best of circumstances that's
why we went ahead and started working
with DPW and Architects to try to be
ready to go at the moment that this
legislature said go
if that's no longer the reality then
that's then that then that is what it is
right the
I would I would want to move as much as
possible as soon as possible because I
feel that if we don't actually get to
work on this what I fear is that we're
not gonna ever get this done I sat in
the hearing room downstairs five years
ago listening to you know people
admonish us for not doing this you know
six months after I walked into New
Hampshire for the first time in my life
and you know frankly it's time to get it
done and um so I'd rather do something
than nothing
to so Madam commissioner yes or no is is
the money to begin the site evaluation
critical or not
I do believe it's critical and and part
of what haunts me is Imagining the
staffing issues that are going to
transpire without any serious plan and I
think that is indicative of forward
movement and it's already going to be
hard enough to keep the place um
functioning safely
thank you representative Weiler well
have you been waiting representative
tolersky because I know representative
Weiler is ready do you do you have
something
it's related to what you were saying
which was a clarification for what we
heard yesterday which was
the it sounded to me and I I guess I'm
trying to figure out if I'm wrong that
yesterday we heard the department is
moving forward in the process of
determining the best site and you did
not need us to give you that green light
to do it you did not need us to give you
the
part of the two million dollars to get
that done so I guess I'm confused as to
what was just exchanged here no
um I'm not I'm not sure exactly what
what you were calling from yesterday or
if I misspoke but the site evaluation
was always intended to be part of the
contract with the with the external
Architects that piece of the work was
through them making the final
determination around Sight can't be done
until that work is done right and that
work was going to be the first part of
what would be done under that contract
so yesterday I remember talking about
that that would be something that would
probably be from my memory because I
haven't looked at the looked at that
proposal recently would have been done
first and probably in a matter of weeks
to a month or so from the start of that
contract so that would be the first
piece of work done on that contract and
that it would therefore be information
that would be available for the
September 30 date for the committee that
was being discussed yesterday but the
site evaluation work was always a
component of what needed to be done to
make a final decision about a location
we couldn't make a final decision
without doing that work
do you have a follow-up
no all right representative Weiler and
then representative norgren
I've been to all three sites
I was a representative for Hampstead for
20 years before redistricting
I've talked with the representatives
from Hampstead and the senator
who was involved in Senate bill one
um
there's more flexibility on Hampstead
than any other site
that's about 100 acres of woods it's
off the beaten path
it's not on a main road
a lot of people in Hampstead don't even
know it's there it's the hospital that
presently exists
and
we talked about
putting it near the site in Manchester
but it would need another kitchen it
would need somebody to provide meals
that isn't there they don't have a
laundry if they get to Hampstead or
Concord they have shared facilities they
could have meals brought
from another facility as well as laundry
but having sat through the review on the
secure psychiatric facility on Concord I
know the limitations that we've heard
about Concord and there isn't that many
places you could try it and the talk of
wetlands and all that stuff so there's
more flexibility and where it would go
and what can be done in Hampstead as
well as providing adjacent services that
puts it out in front in my book
and I don't think the Hampstead people
are going to be objective to it for that
small population and that that uh
plus they're getting the property taxes
I think we've got that included that
they would have lost
by the the Private Hospital being sold
so
I think there's as that was a big a big
stumbling block for Hampstead which has
gone away as far as I'm concerned so
I think that we can we can be certain
that it will end up in Hampstead and
that
you know
they may fine tune it a little more and
pick exactly the site they want in
Hampstead but I think that place has the
most flexibility and is way ahead of the
other sites so I wish we could agree on
this and and get the ball rolling I
don't want to see this happen where
we're always two years behind or maybe
five years behind
um we can't keep kicking the can down
the road let's move and accept this
amendment and pass sb1 and SB 49 they're
both the same we can move forward on
this I hate to see all this delays thank
you uh thank you representative Waller
and uh as as the chair of the committee
let me ask you a question it's getting
close to 1 30 where you said you'd be
pulling us out of recess of the full
Finance it it feels to me like I need
another 20 minutes to be able to give
you a clear recommendation of division
three where we stand on uh this
amendment or any other Amendment get it
done get it done okay thank you sir
representative norgren yeah I
wanted to add to the discussion and I
yesterday I was watching online and I
was texting Mary Jane and Laura because
I I think we have to keep considering
the employees of this organization
um I think all the indecision is hard
for them I think we're everyone's having
trouble retaining employees under the
conditions we have now
so I I think we have
urgency for that reason to make a
decision and get things moving so people
who work there know where they're going
know what they're doing have some
stability in their lives so you can hire
more people in fact
so I just wanted to say that thank you
thank you I don't hear a question in
there unless you want to argue with her
uh representative Stringham do you have
yeah just it seems to me that
um you know down to the minutia of what
uh we're we're talking about uh it
sounds like you're gonna you would need
some appropriation uh to go through the
site evaluation process as you've
described so moving the number from 2
million to zero
um uh would uh hamper your progress
somewhat
um so
um uh you know you know if we more
limited and and by the way I trust you
with my life this is this is just you
know I'm just here to represent the
community and and make sure when we ask
them to pay money that that we're
getting something from it so and I thank
you very much for all your testimony
over the last few days
um so
um and you know I don't know which way
we as a group will will go and you know
continue with this larger package are
limited to a site evaluation
but if there's a number less than 2
million and bigger than zero that would
allow you full flexibility to go through
with the site evaluation what would that
number be the truth is I don't know the
answer to that question right the two
million all these numbers have come from
the Department of administrative
services and the vision of Public Works
who are the experts and how we build
things and everything else in the state
of New Hampshire and in fact DHHS
where the DPW is the the lead on all
these efforts and we're kind of the
client who is Consulting on on you know
what the needs are around these efforts
so anything I would give would be a
total guess and I really you know
somebody else's guess would probably be
better than mine I I would wag 400 000.
that would be My Wag just doing projects
in the past but
um all right any other questions on this
because what I'd like to do now is I
want to get a sense of the division on
lines 25 through 31 I'm going to ask two
things
hopefully it'll it only becomes one
thing I would like to know
yes or no do you accept the language
that's already written on Amendment zero
four five four lines 25 through 31 as is
representative hole
I have no issues with the language I do
ask for a clarification though because
in line 27 we have requests to procure a
qualified architect and then line 28
right which is start the project
immediately I hear that right get the
architect up and running and then in
line 28 I hear a request if you're a
contractor to build and I don't think
that's going in parallel so it's the
same language with two different actions
and I just want to make sure that I
understand or that we somehow document
that this is to get to Define where
we're going but not necessarily go build
and I think I would interpret request a
procure a contractor winning more of an
RFP right request for proposal process
as opposed to issue a PO but that I just
would like that clarified you know I
think I had stumbled on this before and
we had initially written requests for
proposal and that got changed somewhere
on the along the line and and I think
you've picked up a nice little rub there
that we want to figure out the way it
should lay down I I I I the first one I
think is a request to procure because
all the RFP stuff has been done they're
ready to pull the trigger I believe I
did Mr ribson do you want to tell us if
they're both meant to be requests for
procure and if we do tend to limit if we
decide to limit this do we need to
strike that authorization language so
DPW uses multiple different types of
procurement tools
right and again this is outside of my
scope of expertise but I've learned a
little bit trying to go through this
process and they're not they don't
typically use the request for proposal
tool even though that's the tool that we
typically use in vhhs right so the
reason why we used the language procure
was just to be flexible in the type of
public procurement tool that they would
use to not prescribe which tool is
appropriate that they would use the
request for X whatever that is
um based on their you know expertise in
judgment as the best way to publicly
legally appropriately procure that
service
I I just realized I was on the wrong
section we're still on lines 15 through
24 and I I got myself jumbled oh
so so but that was good foreshadowing uh
representative hole would your concern
about the second request for procure
be satisfied if we ended up striking on
line 17 the phrase architect
consultation and development of design
options
I am okay with that I am okay with what
we agreed to yesterday look at both both
are options
um if we're going to change the
the effort right then probably the the
amount spent should also be changed so
so I'll go back to what I meant to say
we're going yes or no do you accept the
language as written for lines 15 through
24.
yes representative Stringham
um I I prefer what you just described so
we'll you you're open to a modification
you don't so you're a no on just
accepting this language well I'm I'm
so I'll say no thank you
uh representative Weiler yes or no on
let's see a problem on 27 and 28 uh it's
it's a request of accurate qualified
architect honor before March 1st and
shall collaborate to issue a request to
procure a contractor to build the
resulting construction project
that's assumes in my mind after you have
the design it doesn't mean they have to
be done at the same moment yeah so it's
The Logical way to read it so you're a
yes on 15 through 24. uh representative
Wallner
no I'm not are you open to tweaking it
to limit it to Simply site evaluation
I I think that's what I brought up with
site location first
um and as far as
money in there I'd have to think about
that for a little while longer and I
don't know that 400 000 is the right
amount but that I would replace that
whole section with
um do you have language right now that
you can offer the committee
we we we're on a March one doesn't
about so you're you're you're you're a
no and you're a no on a simple
modification to just leave site
evaluation
and in the in the dollar amount you're
you're no one either is the dollar
amount 400 000. I I would wag it at 400
000. well do you have a better wag
I don't have the slightest idea what
what it would be I would need some
someone who knew
about um I mean someone like from
administrative Services because that was
the right amount all right 50 years of
judgment like 400 000 is not a bad whack
uh representative tolersky do you accept
the language is written lines 15 through
24. I'm a no on it as written I would be
open to sing you're open to a
modification representative nordgren
you you accept that language as is
no I accept change in the language
you're open to tweaking it
representative Mooney
I would propose uh leaving it as is and
also you brought up a good point that um
I know our discussions could go on in
perpetuity in fact it doesn't change the
date it actually brings the date closer
March 1st actually comes closer with
every moment that we're here
unfortunately so I like representative
Weiler proposed moving this amendment to
our exec session
thank you
okay I I'm I'm so sorry I'm just not
there yet so uh that I my head count is
four four on accepting the language is
is uh for against and now I'm gonna
explore a tweak in a uh and an effort to
get us to say yes to one another
if we changed on line 16
2 million
to four hundred thousand
and we could put a not to exceed in
there just to really you know make that
more clear
uh I don't think the department tries to
waste money so we could make that a not
to exceed four hundred thousand dollars
and on line 17 leave for the purpose of
site evaluation there because we all
agree that's important and then strike
delete from the word development through
the word
what through just design options
development of design options so that
would read for the purpose of site
evaluation for replacement facility for
the sununu Youth Center
that that that is my proposed
alternative language
would you accept that representative
hole
so if I'm reading if I'm hearing what
you said and I'll restate it for
clarification right 16 is now four
hundred thousand dollars 17 we strike
out architect consultation and
development of design options
my concern then is lines 18 and 19 the
department shall develop two design
options we're still mandating that that
happened but we didn't fund it so I
think there's a conflict right a
technical conflict
um that I don't know what to do with
okay so so how about if we strike on
line 19
um
for the shall develop design options
because the rest of this is kind of
clarifying on the site evaluation piece
of this for the site evaluation it's
helpful for them to know
starting on 18 on to 19 the department
for possibilities
for two possibilities a facility with a
capacity of six to twelve and a capacity
of 12 to 18. so at least they know what
they're evaluating I am okay with the
proposed 400 000 for site evaluation to
consider two design options right not
architect not go do detailed engineering
drawings but two conceptual right
and have those as information to present
back to the legislature because
yesterday we spent a lot of time talking
about who's making the decision on where
this goes I don't think there was
agreement amongst the entire division
that the legislature should be making
the decision ultimately on where this is
so the site evaluation and the design
options coming back to us is a good
thing so so my disclaimer on this as we
go flying by is that I know that Mr
Ripple is listening he's following the
antenna he's following the
strikethroughs and when he gets to
writing an amendment to the amendment
he'll he'll he he's probably going to
have a tweak in there that makes it
smooth without killing the intent so
you do that all the time so that that's
where the member of your intent as
discussed okay so uh representative
Stringham modified language would you be
open to that yes or no
um
uh subject to seeing it yes okay
representative Mooney
yes with the caveat though that I think
by taking out the original language we
move further away from Senate bill one
but the answer to your question is yes
okay I think that was a true statement
representative Weiler yes representative
walner
I think I want to see the language but
yes I think I can go with that thank you
for that representative yes upon
reviewing it representative Morgan yes
thank you okay so good uh that part's
unanimous let's let's skinny up the
section on appropriation to to put 400
000 for begin the side evaluation
okay then paragraph four line 25 through
the key thing that this does the most
powerful aspect of this whole section
from my point of view is that final
sentence the sysc shall immediately be
closed for detention or admission of any
child when a replacement facility is
sufficiently completed the children can
be legal and safely housed there that
way we're not facing the guillotine of
an of an of another date we're just
saying let's let's do the replacement
uh is there any other part of lines 25
through 31
that that anyone wants to discuss
Mr chairs as I pointed out earlier and
words matter and yeah versus
um some sort of proposal right are very
different to me so so
I'm not disagreeing I just need words on
line 28 the return request
a change procure to proposal yes please
okay and and the in the and the only
disclaimer there is we don't know the
words that our state uses but the term
request for proposal makes
sense to me
so hopefully our state has a similar
word
okay so you're okay with that with that
change in that word I am representative
Stringham
yeah yes representative Mooney yes
Weiler
representative walner
I'd want to read it but I think with the
word change yeah okay Yep this is all
content contingent upon reading it yes
yes yes representative yes okay again we
got some unanimity with the one word
change on line 28 for requests for to
procure to request for proposal
then on line 32 this is the commission
I recommend we just keep the whole
commission I mean you know we we're
going to go ahead and start the
evaluation process I think this
commission is a vital part of it this
commission is limited in its Authority
it doesn't make any decisions it's going
to be able to write report lines 1
through 33.
just a small Point yes sir
um
uh just to comply with 1449 can we just
G and H representative
rather than representatives and and
perhaps add one House member make it
four and three or something oh okay
let's do one at a time on line 15 and I
think the same thing is going to be true
on line 17. the the word is currently
plural Representatives right so so in in
the way that I've written things that
has been accepted I don't know if my
fifth grade English teacher would agree
but I would put the S of Representatives
in parentheses so it could be a
representative or Representatives
without specifying a number and the
reason for not specifying a number is is
just so that we can do things rationally
if they really get fixated on Hampstead
they can bother the Hampstead people
without trying to get a conquered person
to show up
so so what does that work Mr Ripple if
we just put the S of Representatives in
could
as representative Stringham points out
so RSA 1449 caps the number of members
of the commission at 15 and contains
various other requirements
Senate bill one
actually had language saying
notwithstanding RSA 1449 that I noticed
is missing from this so I would add that
to this language as well tell me what
line item you would put notwithstanding
um
at the beginning of the sentence that's
at the end of line five the commission
shall consist of the following members I
would say notwithstanding RSA 1449 the
commission shall consist of the
following members okay I'm I'm okay with
that I'm not sure what it means but
uh I like saying yes so so so lines 30
if excuse me one through 33 on page two
we've suggested tweaks to add the RSA on
line five and to change representatives
to the parenthetical so that we can get
the right number is there any any
discussion
okay representative Mooney
fine and I would just point out on line
five fire safety has been added for our
well yes we'd added uh other relevant
factors too so yeah right yes yes ma'am
um representative Weiler yes or no
thank you
yes question Mr chair um yes what's
three what's the relationship of the
department to this Commission
commission do you have any ex official
role or what
what's their relationship
well if I read line 10 properly C the
commissioner of the Department of Health
and Human Services or designee is is on
this and I imagine the designee would be
something that looks like a Mr ribson
but yeah
do you have another question do you want
that's the chairman yes
a full committee so we're getting very
close I'm so sorry I I know you're a
fighter pilot
right
you would have a decision yes sir I
thought I'd have a
I I haven't do I thought I'd have a
decision two years ago so uh okay so
you're okay with that I think we're all
okay with lines one through thirty three
and then the rest of it gets into
repeals and effective dates and and uh I
I think we're okay with those
all right
representative hole Stringham
Wyler Waller okay
all right so we have a proposal uh if we
come back and it's exactly like this
can I expect you to vote Yes on this yes
or no
yes
so that's a yes could you speak into the
microphone
thank you representative tolerski I just
wanted to clarify go ahead on reviewing
it yes I would be able to support it
upon reviewing it all right thank you
representative norgren yes thank you all
right and that's that's always implied
you know you have to be able to read it
okay so so uh I think with that uh I'm
ready to to to to to to to recommend to
the whole house or excuse me the full
committee that we adopt uh what will be
the modification to zero four five four
as we've discussed and have Mr Ripple go
make that happen
uh and then the rest of the idea options
49 and uh two uh or 527 I'm gonna I'm
gonna recess that to the next work
session
any comments if you're going to have
another work session then I have to
dismiss the rest of the committee no no
next week we're not going to do that
we're we're SB we're we're acting on sb1
sir we're not we're gonna we're gonna
postpone 49 and 527 until a future work
session that's already being calendared
all right so my point is I've had the
rest of this committee waiting around
this is a result of this
and there is nothing to report I I I
believe there is I believe that we're
working on a fresh Amendment it'll be
coming back as soon as it can and and I
think we have as long as there's no
typographical error in there or uh we're
we're gonna we're gonna recommend to the
the committee acceptance I hope we have
a quorum
okay the way we've been delaying all
this all right so I'd like to adjourn
this meeting
division three is now adjourned how much
I have to inform the rest of the finance
committee
that we'll meet in an hour
or sooner
if there's enough of them here to
how many are there any out people out in
foreign